ladies and gentlemen welcome thank you
for coming my name is John Peters I had
the
Schulman seminar on elemental media and
it's a great delight to welcome you to
the Whitney Humanities Center and to
hear our speaker professor Paul Edwards
on this evening Paul and Edwards is
William J Perry Fellow in international
security at Stanford University and
professor of information history
emeritus at the University of Michigan I
hope you're not watching me you should
be watching this completely spellbinding
animation here and he's the author of a
fast machine which let me get the
subtitle properly computer models
climate data and the politics of global
warming a monumental history that I
recently had the pleasure to reread for
my class and the cold world that's sorry
the cold world the closed world it's a
cold war that's where the interference
is coming from the closed world
computers in the politics of discourse
in Cold War America from 1996 also the
co-editor of a book called changing the
atmosphere expert knowledge in
environmental governance from 2001 in
addition to a wide array of fascinating
and marvelous articles which have had a
huge influence on me and many people in
this room he's one of the leaders in the
infrastructural turn which is leading to
so much lively debate in recent years
and brings together scholars and
scientists in the humanities Social
Sciences and STEM fields especially via
his work on knowledge infrastructures
our lecture series as I mentioned has
the theme of elemental media and Paul
Edwards was at the top of my list in him
you can see how seamlessly a historian
of computing became a historian of
climate science and the way his career
encompasses data machines and global
weather global climate is a lesson in
how we cannot think or act weather
locally or globally in our environment
without media of various sorts there are
no data without models is a famous point
of his book a vast machine but he also
makes the point in passing one that I
would like to emphasize
there are no data without media let me
also note this this Wednesday from 12 to
1 in Kroon Hall you may get this right
as I'm blind Burke auditorium Kroon Hall
professor editors will be speaking on
time and risk in climate knowledge so
there be further opportunities but as
for tonight please join me in welcoming
professor Carl Edwards thank you so much
it's been really a great pleasure to be
here for this visit with John and his
wonderful class and some of you are here
again to see me again
so today I'm going to talk about the
creation of climate knowledge how that
some a bit about how that works and then
talk some about controversies in climate
science that have happened in the last
20 years and kind of where they have
left us today I I need to do a little
bit of setup here the setup involves a
book that was at one time very
well-known called an evolutionary theory
of technological change by Nelson and
winter from 1982 so this book was about
organizations and how they work and
their paradigm for an organization was a
factory you know so like an automobile
factory big organization lots of moving
parts lots of different departments and
aspects and in one of the chapters of
this book they talk about routines as
memory truce and target and here's what
they mean so memory for them is how is
it possible that in any organization
kind of maintains its identity over its
long lifetime you know people come and
go but the organization keeps doing what
it did and one answer to that is that
they develop routines and the routines
are taught to people and everyone knows
them so a new person comes in and they
learn the routine and they just keep on
going and to some degree those routines
often become embedded in technology
that's what we call automation
a second point they make is that there
are truces in any organization and that
routines exemplify them that is you've
got a process and it keeps rolling even
though there are conflicts labor
management you know people have their
issues with each other all kinds of
things and there may be defiance there
may be laziness there may be people
missing steps but because the routine is
there the organization knows how to fill
in those blanks and keep things rolling
even while there are still why those
conflicts happen and the last point they
make is about targets so their idea is
that routines of one sort become the
paradigm or the pattern for routines of
a new type so the organization starts to
do something new make a new kind of car
for example and it takes the routines
that had been using and now applies them
in a somewhat different way to the new
thing all that seems pretty
straightforward now let me apply this a
little bit to climate science so in
climate science one of the major things
that goes on is memory that's how we
know about that's what climate is it's
like the history of weather over very
long periods of time so one thing that
has to happen is that we have to keep
that knowledge you could call it data
but there's more to it than data and as
I'll say talk more about in a minute one
thing you have to do with it is adjust
it because you learn new things about
how old information was made so you need
to change it but in any case you keep a
memory of climatic history there are
also truces in science and that's what
happens when a scientific routine
develops and continues despite conflicts
over things like standards units of
measure of the meaning of a particular
phenomenon and so on and then there are
also targets and a great example here is
that when satellites first became
available for weather information
they you know satellites do a much
different thing than a weather balloon
that can fly's up through the atmosphere
and measures points along a line as it
rises a satellite is seeing a gigantic
volume of air underneath it and
measuring that as a whole thing so the
the weather balloon can take
measurements at points but the satellite
is just seeing one thing radiance at the
top of the atmosphere and that has to be
disaggregated into all the parts of the
structure below it and it's also
measuring a big volume so the satellites
come in what do you do with this data
which they have no way of processing yet
you know weather model and they say well
we'll turn it into radiosonde data we'll
make it look like radiosonde data so
they use various algorithms to translate
it into basically points along a line
now today they've developed better
methods of handling that kind of data
which is so different but that was one
way in which a routine became a target
okay I'm also gonna be talking about
target today in a much different sense
that sense something to shoot at okay I
forgot I was supposed to stand behind
this microphone here so I'm also this is
also a little bit of background I'm
gonna be talking about knowledge
infrastructures and what do I mean by
that so I'm talking about something that
is mostly taken for granted like weather
forecasting you know you probably don't
know or care about how weather forecasts
are made you just look at the weather
forecast and use that to think about
your day and you know that it they're
not perfect and they're it's not gonna
always turn out that way but still if
the weather forecast says it's gonna
rain you're probably gonna take an
umbrella
so they these things are made of people
and equipment and institutions they
generate knowledge about the human world
or the natural world and it's routine
it's reliable it's something that people
accept and just use so examples of these
things there are many are the Census
Bureau which counts our population and
its characteristics the Centers for
Disease Control the Bureau of
labor statistics puts out statistics
every month and wall street goes nuts
you know reacting to those statistics
but it doesn't for the most part
question them it just uses that
information and same thing with this
piece which is these two pieces which
are about weather and climate okay so
here's what I'm going to do we'll talk
some about memory kind of data and
climate models how they work then we're
going to talk about the glass laboratory
the truces in science how science kind
of keeps itself together and then
finally some climate data controversies
and what I'm talking about when I say a
siege on truth okay
so here's one of many things that
climate scientists use as data the ice
core you've heard about these so this is
their drilled out of Antarctica or
Greenland and they are they go very deep
and they collect data about the
atmosphere from the past and they
actually contain bits of the atmosphere
from the past so this is one of the few
pieces of very old climate knowledge
that comes from direct observation as
opposed to proxy measurement so here you
can take a sample of air from 800,000
years ago because it's trapped there in
a bubble in the ice and measure how much
of particular gases is in that bubble so
you you that's how we get measurements
of the past atmosphere they also have
rings like tree rings so you can count
back you know just just like a tree to
know exactly how old that piece of ice
is so climate scientists call these
things archives here the rings and they
really are archives because they
literally contain bits of the past they
they are the history of our climate so I
like to talk about this is not my phrase
but I like this phrase long data because
we talk a lot about big data today but
in the case of climate and climate
change what we really would we actually
care about long data going back into the
past and more recent data about weather
for example has been stored in a whole
variety of media starting with written
records like these is a ship's log where
people just wrote things down by hand
and moving to published books of climate
data this one from 1914 amazing story
because this was one of the first
efforts to collect climate data for the
whole world and these people had to did
that from about 500 stations all over
the world and it took 8 to 12 years to
collect that day
put it into a book from just 500
stations
it seems unimaginable in the age of the
internet but then that's how things
worked they had to come by mail by ship
they had to send back for more
information the reports are delayed or
got lost and and so on then we get the
age of punch cards which actually
predates computers it goes back into the
1920s in the case of weather and climate
data stored on punch cards but that
helps enable the computer revolution
when it happens because these cards can
be used for weather data processing and
then finally today we have huge archives
of data stored on tape libraries this is
one at the National Center for
Atmospheric Research that holds eight
petabytes of data and it's already full
so there are vast amounts of data in
climate science and they go back into
the past as I said they always have to
be adjusted so this example is these are
precipitation gauges in different
countries for both solid and liquid
precipitation now what you're seeing
here is that at a particular moment in
time here between these two years a
windshield was added to this
precipitation gauge and all of a sudden
well not really a sudden over the space
of what's that 14 years the measurement
changed in a sort of stepwise fashion
because the shield is now changing the
what the instrument does it's not
changing how much precipitation there is
it's just changing the characteristics
of the instrument so if you know about
that change you can correct for it
because you know what they used to read
and you know how the effect of the
windshield on the instrument so you then
can adjust the past data to fit with the
present data they call this homogenizing
data here's another example so you can
measure snow cover from satellites but
not very precisely at least at the time
satellites first started they there see
it they're taking pictures
large areas huge areas and to measure
the snow cover they have to figure out
which parts of it are white and which
parts of it are say green or black or
grey because those would be rock or
trees and you want to exclude those from
the the snow cover so they divide up the
whole image into a set of grid squares
and they use some percentage of the grid
square as a yes-no variable so say you
know 70% of the grid square is white
we're gonna call that snow 90% of it is
dark we're gonna not call that snow and
then they put all the grid squares
together and average it out and that
tells you the snow cover so over time
the the people who did these
measurements used different algorithms
to do that processing and then here in
the you know around 1990 they took all
the old data and reprocess them with the
same algorithm so that now they're
measuring it all in a uniform way and
the dashed line is what they had before
the solid line is what they have now
with the same algorithm doesn't really
matter what the changes were what
matters is the the homogeneity of the
process so this record is a better
record of what happened in the past than
the ones that were put out year by year
my last example much more recent this is
from 2015 the national climate archives
put out some new corrections to weather
data and they show you here that they've
made some small Corrections you can see
they're very minimal here's a bigger one
but mostly they're pretty similar to the
old ones let me show you down here what
the data would be like if they had not
done the corrections so these
adjustments are very significant back
here from 1880 until about 1940 and
they're not you know they're using more
or less the same correction
here as here but you see that there you
know really significant adjustment going
on to these data okay
now let's talk about truces so what's a
truce if we look up the word truce on
the Google image search er you get a lot
of pictures of you know here's a white
flag here's people shaking hands mostly
people shaking hands and you know here's
what may be a different kind of truce
but people sort of coming together to
stop fighting right we all know about
that now let's look at a different word
truth if we look this word up on the
image searcher we just get words now
here's the thing these words are
actually the same word etymologically
speaking so in Middle English true is
the singular form of truce true is the
singular form of truce I think that's
fascinating in itself but I think it
really matters for the situation that
we're about to talk about because all
science as I said earlier depends on
truces we stop arguing about something
and we just work we adopt a routine and
we stick with it right let's look a
little bit more at this so what to be
true meant in the middle English is to
be faithful to be loyal to be true to
someone to be true to a promise and
that's where the truce aspect comes in
because we make an agreement and we stay
true to it so we have truths we have
truths
so if you look up the meaning of true in
the OED the first meaning that comes up
is to be loyal to be trustworthy and
things like that so to support and
respect a leader a country a cause be
faithful to one's word so that to be
true to one's word is the what this
first meaning is and only later do we
get sorry the meaning that we often use
today to be true to reality to be a fact
okay what what does this have to do with
science well I like to talk about this
in terms of one of the main features of
science as a form of knowledge which is
that it is in principle in principle
something that is done in public that is
it's not just me doing an experiment in
a little bubble and then telling you
here's the result and you just accept it
it's having others also see that result
happen and in the early days of science
the classic illustration of this is the
Royal Society of London where they're
they have a big arena as it were and
experiments are performed on a stage in
front of an audience so these people who
observe the experiment can all testify
that yes we all saw the same thing and
the modern version of that is something
quite different but it's really in a lot
of ways the same thing let's see let me
get this all out it's publication which
literally means to make public right so
you do an experiment or you collect some
data and you make them public and one of
the things that you do there is provide
a description of how you reached your
result that's the methods section of
every scientific article now methods
sections never tell it really tell you
enough to reproduce a result but they
are
at least the stab at that and it comes
from this older tradition of witnessing
in in person and transforms it into what
people shape it in Schaffer called
virtual witnessing so now we witness
just by reading about what they said
they did in that world where you do this
where you publish things in the distant
world of the 20th century 19 years ago
your data and any models you made belong
to you
their intellectual work product and you
might you know if you publish data what
you actually publish is not the long
long table of every measurement you took
but the graph that shows a synthesis of
all those data or something similar to
that
similarly with models people almost
never actually published computer code
in the past they would just describe an
algorithm and the coding was left to you
know to them and in fact people would
resist very strongly giving up their
computer code because again that's work
product that's that's my special thing
that I contribute
so when peer review comes in peer review
is also a form of virtual witnessing and
it you know the peers almost never
actually review data or models directly
they review the synthesis of it they
review the algorithm but they don't
review all the details of how the result
is reached that has all changed in the
last 20 years so today it's much more
common for people to publish their data
and publish their code and many journals
actually require that you do that so
another question here is what is peer
review who counts as a peer so remember
I said in principle it's public in
principle but the first peers were
people like that they were English
gentlemen
and they had to be gentlemen they were
not allowed to join the Royal Society
unless they were gentlemen and they were
always men they were considered to be
valid observers of experiments because
they were gentlemen and part of what
that meant was that they didn't have any
stakes in the outcome because they were
wealthy they were also presumed to be
intelligent and educated so you know
servants women kind of ordinary people
just not even considered potential peers
that's a day we you know later we get an
image more like this where now we've got
a couple of women in the picture but you
know they're all clearly wearing white
coats they're scientists and maybe today
you will see a little more diversity
like that in science but often it's
still white men doing this and highly
educated highly trained so it's not
literally public in a sense that anyone
anyone can comment it's only other
experts who are recognized as peers by
this institution of science we'll come
back to that later okay
so here's a major truce in science this
is about weather forecasting this is to
how the world weather forecast system
works we have observing instruments in
space in the air at sea on land they go
they send data to giant computers in a
few places all over the world they
crunch all those numbers they use a
simulation model to create a weather
forecast and they send it out to
National Weather Service's who then make
their own Corrections and adjustments
and local forecasts and send it out to
you this was designed in the early 1960s
and actually was functioning well before
that in other ways and all through this
process and even now there are conflicts
all the time over standards the way it
should be organized the kind of
technology that should be used the
you questions about violation of
sovereignty questions about money should
you pay for these data or not is there
many many conflicts going on and yet it
continues to work in the climate space
here's another example of a truce
the IPCC Intergovernmental Panel on
Climate Change and you know full
disclosure I serve on that panel now I'm
working on the sixth assessment report
I've not done this before but I've been
part of it since July I sorry since last
June IPCC is basically the world
consensus body of climate scientists it
started with a few dozen people writing
the first report in 1990 this is
mandated by the United Nations it's part
of the Framework Convention on Climate
Change so it's not a you know that they
didn't make this up they kind of came
together because they were asked to do
this and they've done a series of
assessments over the last 29 years at
this point and what you see here is a
steady increase in certainty about the
nature of climate change so here we
can't tell if it's signal or noise yet
but we will some time soon the next
three reports go from balance of
evidence suggests a discernible human
influence to new and stronger evidence
to very likely which means in IPCC
language about an 80% plus probability
to extremely likely in the last report
which in it has a numerical value in
IPCC language so it means that there is
95 percent confidence that human
activity is responsible for much of the
observed warming since the mid 20th
century not necessarily all but much of
it okay so this is another kind of truce
and now let's talk about some targets
because as this develops you start to
get resistance and some of it is genuine
skeptics
and some of it is highly motivated
reasoning put out there and supported by
by industries that have stakes in the
outcome notably fossil fuels so I'm
gonna go very quickly through this which
is older but it's still it's an
important beginning point so the hockey
stick is a graph of the last 1,000 years
of temperature and what it seemed to
show in 1998 when it came out was that
the present phase that the last 20-30
years are warmer than it has ever been
globally in the last 1,000 years so this
guy named Steve MacIntyre who was a
retired Canadian mining engineer with a
good head for numbers and knows his way
around a spreadsheet noses understands
statistics he did not like this result
and he decided that he would investigate
it very deeply his idea was this is not
a stupid idea he would say if you're a
corporation you have books and in order
to convince your shareholders that you
are actually earning money you need to
have your books audited if the person
who audits your books works for you
that's corrupt because they have an
incentive to tell you what you want to
hear and the shareholders too so you get
your books audited by an independent
auditor who doesn't work for you so
MacIntyre would say we need to audit
climate science the auditors can't be
climate scientists because they have an
incentive to sort of promote more
climate science I guess
so nuts this blog in the early days of
blogging and this became one of the most
popular climate related websites in the
world and still is in fact and he then
proceeded to challenge the hockey stick
graph over and over again and blew this
up into a national episode so he asked
for so Michael Mann was one of the
authors of this
Graff he asked for man's data man said
here's some of it I'm gonna give you the
rest on an FTP site you know you go get
it do what you want with it
MacIntyre then asked for the source code
and man said no that's my intellectual
work product we published the algorithm
write your own code that didn't satisfy
MacIntyre who then went to you know took
this to the US House subcommittee it got
reviewed by the National Science
Foundation the National Research Council
the triple-a s the National Academy of
Sciences and others and it this
controversy is weirdly still going on
even though in a lot of ways this is a
settled issue the National Research
Council review so the red line here is
the hockey stick or a somewhat later
version of it by the same authors and
you know so here's the last thousand
years and you and we're here in about
two thousand three or four but time
these data stop and it's showing that
clearly there is you know there's a lot
of error bars here but at the same time
there's a lot the temperature rise
recently is higher than any point in the
last 1,000 years now here's the reason
that MacIntyre got upset and they're
still upset about this there was this
graph that came from 1965 by an
excellent British climatologist named
Hubert lamb that lamb had some data from
northern Europe England Iceland few
other places and one or two data points
in the southern hemisphere with mostly
northern and he made this graph which
was very rough that showed there was a
period or right around this time when it
was much warmer even than you know the
very recent past and they call that the
Medieval Warm Period this is now known
as the northern hemisphere medieval
climate anomaly because it according to
man and his group this was not a global
phenomenon but only a northern
hemisphere phenomenon
was real but just didn't cover the whole
globe so they had more data and then all
these other groups also investigated the
same thing and came to more or less
similar conclusions which you can see
here you know there's some pretty wide
variation but nobody is going up above
where man and his group saw it so this
idea of the the audit of climate science
spread and we began to see a lot of
these some of them by groups some of
them by individuals you know these two
at the top of the list are kind of the
official data centers in the UK and in
in in the US and here these four people
including a guy named five people a guy
named just Chad have done their own
audit of the data and you can see that
they have you know they vary somewhat
but the general trend is the same across
all of them
and I can show you many more graphs like
this that represent these audits of
climate data this case this next case is
really one of those fascinating to me so
this is an entity called surface
stations org there's a website
constructed by this guy Anthony watts
who is a TV meteorologist he Anthony
Watts runs a blog called Watts up with
that which is the most visited climate
website on the Internet
and if you hook up any piece of climate
data you will soon you will find what's
up with that graphs I guarantee you
within the first 20 or 30 images often
in the first two or three so these are
very widely read and popular so what has
decided that the real problem was not
actual anthropogenic global warming but
the urban heat island effect so that
means that you know weather stations
used to be out in the country in a place
it was just a green field
and then a city got built around them
and now it's asphalt and cars and
factories generating heat and it's
causing an artificial rise in
temperature so to test this theory he
enlisted with this website volunteers to
take the weather service manual for
evaluating weather stations and go visit
them and he said take a camera write it
all down document it show every you know
follow the manual do exactly what it
says and come back and bring us your
results so this citizen science project
eventually surveyed almost all the
weather stations in the u.s. historical
climatology Network now here's what they
found and it is in fact quite surprising
so here you've got this is M mts is the
the temperature sensor and here it is
next to a parking lot air conditioning
unit exhaust fans and a cell phone tower
you know not good here's another sensor
is sort of crammed into a box of
electronics there are many many other
examples and photos on the website and
Watson's conclusion was nine out of ten
stations are reporting biased high
temperature so then they break it down
like this and so the orange in the red
are stations that are reading two to
five degrees or more higher than they
should be
because of this siting problem meaning
the location of the instruments now if
that's true that's terrible you know
this is a massive bias in the in the
weather record well they're really
interesting sequel to this story is that
the group that manages the historical
climatology Network took the data from
this survey and checked it
so they collected all the data they're
looking at you know especially at the
three four and five ratings the high
biased ratings and all these red
triangles are places where Noah itself
the Weather Service verified that yes
the sighting problems documented by the
volunteers were real so they did a
pretty good job
and in fact correspond with NOAA's own
measurement of the station but then it
turns out that it doesn't have the
effect that Watts wants it to have
because Watts is an active climate
change denier turns out first of all
that there was a change in
instrumentation and the new some of
these stations not all and the new
instruments had a lower temperature gave
lower temperature readings than the
previous instruments so that already
brought it down but then the other thing
that's going on is that NOAA is
constantly adjusting data based on what
it knows about things like that
what Watts showed so when they compare
these the good sites the poor sites and
this black line is the research network
of really sort of well sighted stations
that have been developed to be the kind
of benchmark record they all look pretty
much the same and in fact if there's any
bias here turns out that if there is a
bias at all it's actually negative not
positive so widespread poor site
exposure is real but the adjustments
account for it and if there's a bias
it's negative no evidence that the
trends are inflated so
the point I'm trying to illustrate here
is that you know in these two cases we
have scientists doing the routines that
they do but the truces that have
separated one public from another you
know at the scientific small scientific
universe from the much larger public are
being broken down they're being you know
they're people are saying we're not
taking it anymore we're gonna now check
but in these two cases and what happened
was basically confirmation of the
existing science all right my last case
here is this this is the Berkeley
Earth's surface temperature project this
is an unflattering picture of Richard
Muller I should take that off and give
him a less sort of terrifying appearance
because he's a very serious scientist
he's a physicist at Berkeley and Muller
was also skeptical of anthropogenic
global warming so Muller decided that he
would check he was going to make his own
global temperature record this is a much
more ambitious project than Anthony was
so they were going to now collect every
surface station reading that's ever been
made and do their own analysis using
their new independently developed
adjustment system so he recognizes it's
got to be adjusted but we're not gonna
trust the way it's been done we're gonna
do it our own way and they do it in this
is very recent this is since about 22
think they started in 2009 or 2010 and
they have an open methodology an open
dataset they published their their data
and their code you can download the
whole thing why are they doing this well
if you look back at the past you know
there are lots of different data records
these are all made at different times so
they're using different numbers of
instruments and different method of
adjustment but you see that back here in
the 19th century there's some really big
differences I mean this difference is as
big as the claim to go global
today so if this were real it would be a
you know a serious issue but time goes
on and the black line is the most
current record yet at the time this
graph was made in 2006 and you see it
you know back from about 1900 they begin
to agree pretty well but computers have
made a big difference across this time
period now those early ones are all done
by hand calculation prone to error and
they can't do a lot of stations because
it's just too much math so they use more
and more stations as time goes on and
then here in 1986 we get the first kind
of computer processed record and then a
you know another one later it's just a
successor to this same people doing it
but Muller has now quintupled the number
of stations that are being sorry that's
that's not the right number is it does
is like a factor of nine times the
number of stations that that had ever
been used before so they have a gigantic
record now here's the interesting side
story so Watts remember him he has said
he's been watching Muller and he says
this is a great Muller the skeptic is
checking the data he's doing his own
audit and he's gonna tell us the truth
now we're gonna find out what's really
happening we're gonna trust Muller and
Muller is then called up to Congress to
testify before the study is published
but after the preliminary results are in
and he gets up on the stand and he says
well we finished our preliminary results
and guess what they look pretty much
like all the other results so Muller
convinced himself he now he's done a
sort of weird curve fitting exercise
with carbon dioxide but he's convinced
not only that the warming is real but
the carbon dioxide and other greenhouse
gases are causing it so here's another
case where we've got an independent
audit challenging the data and the
methods that are used by mainstream
science
finding that in fact the mainstream
scientists have done their job pretty
well all right
now unfortunately we have to come to
today so the phenomenon I've been
talking about works like this
it used to be that scientists did their
work in public but really it wasn't in
public it was kind of in a small public
space but most people were just out of
its is like the laboratories out there
in the woods even though it's made of
glass but today the laboratory you know
is right in the middle of a huge city
and anyone who wants can look in the
window and see what's going on we
publish all our data we publish all our
code you can download it you can check
it yourself so much bigger challenge for
kind of maintaining the integrity of
science in an environment like this and
then lots and lots of other things start
to happen one is that because of the
Climategate episode that I didn't talk
about when a lot of email was stolen and
released from a Climate Research Unit in
England email came to be seen as a form
of metadata so scientists talking to
each other on email about what about
their work certainly is part of the work
process and they're gonna say thanks to
each other about well we should do this
or we should do that or no that's a bad
procedure we should use this other
procedure and they might say other
things too it would be a little less
savory so some of the Climategate emails
seem to show that these people were kind
of interfering with peer review of
skeptical papers and some other kinds of
things and this launched a flood of FOIA
requests on climate science institutions
so this is an example there are many
many others where what will happen is
that these kind of denialist groups will
FOIA not just once but many many times
you know a hundred times or more some
institution and say we want to see all
your email that contains the name
Michael Mann because he's the often the
villain in this story for them
so this is really a use of no FOIA is
not a bad plan it's a good thing
Freedom of Information Act this is how
we keep an eye on the government this is
a way of keeping things more transparent
but in this case it's being used in a
different mode which is as a deliberate
attack on an institution to slow it down
and confuse it because people have to
respond to these requests it takes time
it takes money and lawyers and it's very
very complicated so here is a legal firm
energy and environment legal it
specializes in FOIA requests and its
slogan is free-market environmentalism
through strategic litigation I'm not
quite sure what that means but you can
see what they're you know you can get
the hint of what they're doing here just
by looking at the list you know so
they've been sending FOIA to the EPA the
Department of the Interior and it you
know go on down the list and there are a
lot of universities on this list if you
follow it down the ladder with the Trump
administration we've start to see a lot
of things that are really very dubious
scientifically one of them is this idea
that there should be a Red Team Blue
team kind of cage match on television
between scientists who think global
warming is happening and that it's
caused by people and scientists who
don't now that is a recipe for kind of a
media event but it's not a recipe for
good science you know as my colleague
Richard Rhodes said about this these
this is more like Heath Ledger's Joker
in the Dark Knight causing disruption
distortion and chaos than like a taking
a testable hypothesis and checking it we
have this theory that has become very
popular in some circles that somehow
getting a research grant is corrupting
that the
motive of climate scientists is to
create more research for themselves so
that they can get more grants and that
therefore getting a grant somehow
focuses you on you know you will find
anthropogenic global warming because
you're getting the money now the the I
think a lot of what this argument is
about is that people most people don't
understand what a research grant is you
know they think it's a grant that you
know I am now going to be paid to do
something in science most research
grants are really for graduate students
for instruments for data analysis
computer time things that scientists
need in order to do their work not about
personally enriching themselves in fact
that's never part of it
you might get part of your salary from
it but your salary is not going to rise
as a result of getting a research grant
so an example of this is what happened
at Scot Pruitt's EPA when he was still
in there he has he said that scientists
who advised the EPA can no longer take
grants from it but of course the
scientists who know the most about what
the EPA works on are the ones who get
grants from the EPA so he is now at you
know actively excluded a whole community
you know that they now have to make a
choice I'm gonna try to seek a grant
elsewhere and work maybe not be able to
find it because I'm not working on these
very special problems that the EPA works
on or I can be on the advisory board
same strictures did not apply to
industry groups so you know here's the
theory of in the form of a cartoon you
know the 95 percent of climate
scientists who agree are just doing it
for the money now if you bounce this
against the amount of money that fossil
fuel companies spend on lobbying there's
no contest
as soon as we as Trump came into office
they basically announced that we are
just gonna reject the whole thing we're
throwing it out so this is the siege
part and the way the siege is beginning
to work is that instead of going after
the outputs as in the past there's lots
of instances in the past of political
entities interfering with the results of
climate investigations trying to make
you know sort of water them down a
little bit when they're finally
published this is different this is
going after the whole institution and
after the inputs to climate knowledge so
we're just not going to pay for it
so in each of the last three Trump
budgets so there was a 2017-2018 and now
there's a 20-19 in each of these three
budgets there's been a proposal for a 37
percent cut to the climate arm of the
National Oceanic and Atmospheric
Administration now for weird reasons
having to do with negotiating in
Congress none of this has actually
happened but this is what the proposal
has been so if you're Noah and you are
ordered by the you know you're part of
the executive branch you're ordered by
the government to find 37 percent of
your budget to cut you have to then
present a document you know here's what
we're going to cut and here is what they
proposed in the 2019 budget summary and
these are you know these are sort of
bureaucratic documents but they're
really worth reading because you can see
what the scientists think about these
cuts from reading their description of
the cut so here we are climate research
they're going to eliminate you know 48
million dollars in climate research
grants this will reduce funding for
cooperative Institute's universities
NOAA Laboratories other partners that
advance understanding of the Earth's
climate system and down here eliminate
Arctic research we're going to cut 5
million bucks from Arctic research
this reduction will terminate Arctic
research focused on improvements to sea
ice modeling and predictions that
support fishermen commercial shippers
cruise ships and local communities so
you know these the people who are
writing the budget think this is a
terrible idea and they're telling you
that and there are more examples of this
in the budget I won't bore you with them
but and then one of them were serious
things that would if it were ever
enacted have a really damaging effect on
climate sciences eliminating certain
satellite missions because you know
satellites take a long time to design
and then to launch and to calibrate and
they they propose to eliminate all four
of these missions this is the weirdest
one so this satellite was originally
proposed by Al Gore and it was actually
built in the 1990s while Gore was vice
president but then it was mothballed by
the George W Bush administration so
sitting there doing nothing and then it
was launched under Obama so it's out
there in space and they proposed to save
a million dollars a year you know
microscopic fraction of the budget by
canceling the data analysis just for
that instrument there are other
instruments on the satellite they'll
still be analyzed but not this one
because that's Al Gore's satellite okay
so the last couple of point the last
thing else to talk about with respect to
the seas just happened on February 20th
so just a few days ago so this guy will
happen this is an interesting case
because will happen is a serious
physicist he works at Princeton he is
emeritus he's but he's almost 80 years
old and he has just been appointed to
head this climate panel that will now
challenge all existing climate science
for the Trump administration habour is
not a fool and he is a he's a serious
scientist but his last work on carbon
dioxide was in 1982 when he actually
wrote a paper
ding serious increase in global warming
from carbon dioxide he's become
convinced since then that that's not
really happening that actually carbon
dioxide will be a benefit to the planet
we should have more of it he doesn't
he's not climate scientist he's a
physicist who works mostly on optics and
he doesn't really understand a lot of
the dynamics of climate but he is still
going to be the head of this panel so
we're gonna see this play out now
they're you know they're they're really
doing this and this is the equivalent
this was the replacement for the cage
match concept all right let me sum up
here we used to have a system in which
authority and trust came from expertise
that was certified by being a
professional scientist these communities
were small they reviewed each other in
journals their data and models they kept
to themselves data analysis required a
lot of skill and specialized tools that
most people could not use even if they
had them and this expertise required a
lot of training the day we've got a new
paradigm coming in in which we're not
worrying as much about where the
authority what the certification for the
authority is it's based more on
messaging and repetition and lots and
lots of venues out there there are
journals there are sorta journals or
kind of real but not really there are
fake journals there's fake news there
are blogs
we've got all the data and code out
there so people can take them and use
them but maybe not understand what
they're using we have tools for
analyzing data and doing statistics that
are easily available to anyone so there
are now millions of people who have the
skills to run statistical models and
digest data and do all kinds of
interesting things with it but again may
not may lack the understanding of the
causal physics of the climate system
but this has not erased the need for
extensive training to understand what
you're doing so that piece is still on
the table what's gonna happen I don't
know
I think the deep cuts in budgets are not
going to materialize because of the the
house controls the purse strings and the
house is not going to do that so that's
not an issue but there are going to be
other kinds of things and one of them is
just a general diminishment of trust in
this science among the public due to
efforts like that hap annal that's about
to be organized so what's going to
happen maybe other instruments agencies
nations will pick up some of the slack
maybe the private sector will help maybe
these big tech enterprises like Google
or Microsoft they already have done some
working in that space what's going to
happen to the Framework Convention we
don't know the US has pulled out but
won't be successive finished with that
for another year or so and then the
really big question for me is whether
we're going to end up with a new truce
in which we really agree to put aside
some of these fights and go with facts
and reality or whether we're going to
still have divisions based around
loyalty to some kind of cause so I'll
stop there
Thanks
[Applause]
thank you for that fascinating please
yeah that's it
go ahead
now that's real and the reason is that
you know so first of all there's kind of
a sort of climatic dividing line at the
equator the winds go opposite directions
north from the equator and south from
the equator and the southern hemisphere
is mostly ocean so the ocean is a
moderating influence on temperature
because it's you know it holds much more
heat and it's much more stable so we
expect to see this at the North Pole and
it's still happening at the South Pole
but there's less of it well that's kind
of beyond my paygrade but let's see
so the IPCC report on keeping
temperature increase to one and a half
degrees came out in the fall and
basically what it says is that we have
to peak peak emissions in 2030 and then
we have to drop rapidly to zero and
actually even below zero we have to
start sucking carbon out of the
atmosphere somehow if we are to achieve
a goal like that it would imply a pretty
high price on carbon you know there no
one thought that the one and a half
degree goal was going to be easy to
achieve there's so better and better
evidence that that would be a really
good idea that two degrees is not a you
know there will still be some rather
catastrophic changes at two degrees so
but we're probably headed there you know
there's a lot that could happen between
now and 2050 to
to change this price on carbon would be
one way of doing it but there are lots
of other mechanisms and just read
yesterday I haven't followed up on this
to find out exactly what happened but
the EU the head of the EU announced that
they would put a trillion euros into the
energy transition
one out of four EU da e EU euros for the
next few years so if that's real that's
a that could be a game-changer and China
too has done an amazing turn on on away
from coal and toward renewables and
reforestation and they're still building
coal plants but they cancelled hundreds
of contracts that we're going to go
through and they've they're building
solar at an unbelievable rate so it's
you know it is possible it is a very
very big project and as long as the u.s.
is not on board it's gonna be very hard
to sell
a section which is on biology
biology and so we came to and they came
in every Tuesday there and he went a
textbook on violence and I said would
you like to talk to us about just
physics he said won't get around to that
but first one get this book
so which experience but inside that cage
[Music]
but no thanks
[Music]
a lot of them are operating on a
organization
[Music]
[Music]
some kind of argument
[Music]
yeah yeah sure well I just want to say
about that at least getting you just
different slides yep um yeah we'll just
we'll just shut this down uh I guess it
doesn't wash it doesn't want to quit so
communication this is a big issue
because we we tend to have I tell you
what I'll just disconnect it from the
there we go you can stare at the blue
screen instead so the language that
scientists tend to use is often really
opaque and that's been one of the issues
about climate sciences so one of the
favorite words of climate scientists the
first word I heard in a lot of
interviews when I was starting to do
research on this back in the early 1990s
was uncertainty you know they would
always say there's a lot of uncertainty
around this but and then it go on well
this is kind of like what my Aikido
instructor used to say never block with
your face
this is leading with your weakest point
right because of course there's
uncertainty you know it's science we
don't know everything you want to you
want to lay that out there but for a
long time for decades that was always
the leading line and the thing is that
when most people hear that word what
they hear is I'm not sure or even I've
got no idea so it's it's it's a fine
word for scientists but it's not a fine
word for communication about science
similarly there are lots of similar
examples as greenhouse gases what does
that mean you know so a better word
would be heat trapping gases uncertainty
what would be better range because you
know it's not that we don't know
anything is that there's you know we're
not sure within some range which is
exactly the right value and you can list
many many examples like this so there's
been this kind of gap between the
scientific communication and the public
communication about it it's being it's
starting to be filled in really creative
ways both by the scientists and by
professional communicators who work on
this and have you know so I told the
class this earlier that I've got a
colleague who's been doing workshops
with meteorologists TV meteorologists
and her what she's doing is encouraging
them to every time they talk about a you
know a phenomenon like a hurricane or a
fire to say and here's what the
statistics were on fires or hurricanes
in this area you know 30 years ago and
here's how they've changed because of
climate change
you know just lay it out over and over
again but to do it in the context of
things that people pay attention to and
that they understand
I still don't understand the best
interests corporations on the the social
media that are spreading so many other
countries it's like you know several
decades ago creationism yeah well
unfortunately they're not and you know
but it is definitely bad yeah well you
know I think the organized politics of
it are there's a lot to know about this
I mean so Naomi Oreskes here at Conway
have a great book called merchants of
doubt that goes through this whole
history of denialism and the weird and
interesting thing is that it actually
starts in the 60s with tobacco
so tobacco and cancer and there the
argument was we don't know enough maybe
tobacco isn't really causing cancer you
know delay delay delay and then of
course later we find out through
documents that they knew in fact had
done their own science the showed it
caused cancer and just covered it up
that's been happening so that they
recount that history for tobacco acid
rain ozone depletion and climate change
and the strangest thing of all this is
the same people so you get certain
individuals Fred Seitz Fred singer half
a dozen others who move serially from
one issue issue to the next and always
say the same thing there's too much
uncertainty and the key to it is that
the last line is always and we can't
afford it so if you see that wine you
know you're dealing with somebody who's
got a certain kind of perspective on
this and it's always been so they also
work through a series of think-tank so
they develop so Cato Institute Heartland
George Marshall Institute there are a
few others you know that become kind of
professional professional denialists
and publish you know white papers and
things that look very respectable have a
lot of political connections so it's
been built up over a much longer period
in this country than elsewhere and you
know the fossil fuel companies fund a
lot of that stuff but there's also to a
certain degree a kind of there's a Cold
War influence on it but among people who
think that the you know ultimately if
you try to stop climate change that's
going to be so expensive and the only
way you can do it is with socialism
seriously I mean you know this is really
what they believe
[Music]
there have been some yeah that's always
my question yes in fact and there have
been some major document dumps in the
last two or three years from ExxonMobil
and shell especially that show that back
in the 1970s these corporations funded
their own climate scientists who told
them that carbon dioxide was going to be
a problem for their product and they
covered it up so there are lawsuits
going on now against those companies for
this you know active denial of something
really really important about the
product that they sell
yeah
[Music]
yeah well I mean so I'm just expressing
my personal view on this okay so this is
not you know I have a lot of knowledge
behind this but I'm not saying this as a
scientist so you're right nuclear power
has been pushed I mean really since the
1990s as a green alternative because
it's very low carbon I mean there is no
energy source that is zero carbon not
even wind or solar because they use
carbon and manufacturing and mining and
stuff like that nuclear is very low
carbon not as low as solar or wind but
still low okay
nuclear power plants are not economical
anywhere in the world now and I just
heard this from a Chinese nuclear
engineer but China is still building
them because it needs the energy and the
cost is not the object at this point
China can do that because of the nature
of its government that's unlikely to
happen here without some real push from
government for you know we already the
government already ensures all nuclear
power plants there's no private
insurance company anywhere that ever has
or ever will take on nuclear power
because the scale of the accident
potential so governments have to do that
my view about it is that in places that
have
stable governments and very
well-developed
technical systems nuclear power is
probably something we need because we
are not gonna get out of this fast
enough with renewables I mean the base
of renewables is very small and even
though it's growing at an exponential
rate now and it's cheaper than
everything else we're not gonna get to
2050 with you know zero carbon with
renewables alone so a lot of other
people say this too it's it's you know
very common among the climate scientists
I know to say we have to have nuclear to
solve this problem the political reality
in this country is that that's almost
impossible you're just not going to get
it and you know we've seen with
Fukushima and Three Mile Island and
Chernobyl that there are these
catastrophic accident potentials lots of
people have ideas for powerful nuclear
power plants that are kind of inherently
safe and maybe that can work thorium
reactors but it's always it's it costs a
lot of money the outcome is not certain
and it's not well supported by the
public so yeah
is there good you know I don't know to
say that you know the sort of the filter
bubble effect is very strong now and
often you know what happens is that the
audiences that I talked to already agree
with me and there's no you know there's
no nothing for me to teach in a lot of
ways most of the engagement sort of
negative engagement I get is on the
internet when you know various things I
post on Facebook or sometimes I I mean
the news a little bit and then I'll get
some nasty comments and the most
interesting one right now is I have a
former colleague from the University of
Michigan who's become a Republican
politician in New Mexico and you know he
posts all kinds of crap about climate
change you don't know anything about it
and but what I've been trying to do with
him is say look you know let's have a
truce basically lets you know come talk
to me about this and we'll we'll just
have a conversation about the facts and
I can show you some articles I'll show
you some graphs here's a piece from MIT
or
ever that might sway you hasn't changed
his mind yet but it's I really feel like
this this whole debate is one person at
a time and you have to be in there and
you have to hang in there with them and
keep going after them and try to do it
in a civil way you know it's hard to do
[Music]
Wow
and he's not scientist by any stretch of
the imagination I think well yeah so the
the the statistics from that program are
basically that about 10 to 12 percent of
Americans are really hardcore denialists
the rest are somewhere in between you
know a lot of them are just don't don't
know and don't care but they're the the
the large majority 60-plus percent think
that climate change is happening and
think that people are causing it and
think the government should do something
about it
that goes for conservatives as well as
Democrats there's higher among Democrats
but it's still a majority of
conservatives and I was saying to john's
class earlier that one of the stranger
things is that of that 60% only 30%
talked to their friends about it because
they think that other conservatives are
all denialists yeah and it's a you know
it's kind of like that's what happened
to Nazis yeah
spiral of silence exactly yeah
what do you think like yeah of course
that's that polarization has also
happened with other issues but the
climate change issue is really weird
because it's so in case everybody didn't
hear that so Democrats and Republicans
mostly agreed in the mid 1990s and today
is a huge polarization so Riley Dunlap
who does a lot of polling in this area
has been doing it for thirty years he
told me that of all the issues that
divide left and right so abortion gun
control taxes everything climate change
is the hardest one to move the needle on
and I think part of the answer to your
question is that it was done in this
very deliberate and professional manner
by these think tanks and very
well-funded advertising campaigns I mean
so naomi has all these slides of ads
that were published all over the country
in the mid-1990s that just sort of said
is the planet warming you know snows
falling in Tennessee and you know things
like that over and over and over again
so the strategy of sowing doubt became
really mainstreamed and amplified
massively in media campaigns my favorite
one of these was you guys know Ted
Kaczynski was the Unabomber sent in mail
bombs to people so Heartland Institute
put up a billboard near me and when I
lived in Michigan said do you still
believe in global warming so does Ted
Kaczynski that kind of went too far even
for some of their funders and they and
they lost some donors after that but you
know both of these it's it's very
manipulative media campaign that's been
very effective
[Applause]
[Music]